Okay, let’s talk about The Wall.
The Wall is a multimedia project created by
English rock band Pink Floyd, consisting of
a 1979 studio album, a live performance touring
over 1980 and 81, a 1982 experimental film,
a 2010 through 2013 revival tour, a 2015 concert
film, and a 2016 opera.
The plot of all the various adaptations center
around a rock star named Pink who struggles
with depression and substance abuse.
In the midst of an emotional spiral Pink reflects
on/hallucinates the events of his life that
have led to that point, including vivid fabrication
of the death of his father in World War 2,
hazy memories of The Blitz, his relationship
with his mother, creative dissatisfaction,
a decaying marriage, and a job in the music
industry where he is treated as a commodity
to be used, all of which form the metaphorical
bricks in the emotional wall that Pink uses
to separate himself from the world.
I want to focus in mostly on the 1982 film,
because it is, I think, the adaptation that
is able to do the most with the concept.
The film was written by Pink Floyd frontman
Roger Waters, directed by Alan Parker, with
animation by Gerald Scarfe, and it is, well,
it’s a pretty heavy film.
It can be a hard watch.
It comes from a very dark place, emotionally
speaking, there’s a lot of disturbing imagery.
It’s a very angry film.
[singing] When we grew up and went to school
there were certain teachers who would hurt
the children any way they could.
It’s pretty abstract in its presentation,
relying heavily on associative imagery rather
than conventional narrative, and this is both
a strength and a weakness for the film.
Abstraction is, counter-intuitively, very
efficient.
It allows a movie to be about a lot of things
simultaneously by letting symbols bleed into
one another.
The movie pinballs between war, classism,
police brutality, the criminalization of youth
culture, Thatcherism, generational trauma,
commodification of art, and the home-grown
fascism of the nations that bragged about
beating the Nazis, and it’s able to do this
pretty fluidly.
The film’s underlying anger is, true to
form, often incoherent, struggling to vocalize
and manifest the exact shape of the subject,
falling back on abstract imagery in order
to suggest an emotional truth where literalism
is insufficient.
This allows the film to create really powerful
moments.
A running motif is anti-war, expressed as
a seething rage of betrayal, abandonment,
and exploitation at the hands of the system.
Roger Waters’ father was a conscientious
objector during World War 2, a pacifist who
drove ambulance during The Blitz.
In 1943, however, he changed his mind and
was commissioned as a Second Lieutenant in
the Territorial Army in September of that
year.
He was dead five months later.
In ‘Goodbye Blue Skies’ the Union Jack
shatters into pieces.
For all its bravado and blustre, English nationalism
is just blood in the gutter.
Soldiers sent to war don’t die for their
country, they just die.
The boys beat the Germans and came home just
in time to build atom bombs.
Symbols shift and merge and break apart, juxtaposed
and contrasted in order to create an impression
of their interconnected relationship in a
way that is difficult to do using mere words
and, core to the theme of the piece as a whole,
no one specific thing is the load-bearing
cause.
There is no singular source of the sickness
in society that isolates us from one another,
that suppresses us, that brutalizes us, that
exploits us.
They are all just bricks in the wall.
This abstraction, though, can also work against
the film.
A lot of the film’s imagery, almost forty
years later, has an almost juvenile Makes-U-Think
shallowness to it, worn down by a generation
of trite commentary on the relationship between
art and commerce, in no small part directly
influenced by The Wall, that cheapens The
Wall simply by association.
The lack of a concise resolution, the lack
of a clear point at the end, which functions
for some viewers as a powerfully disquieting
denial of closure also leaves the door open
for symbols to take on meanings counter to
their intended or desired use.
A centerpiece moment in the film comes when
Pink, suffering an overdose, is revived by
his manager and record industry flunkies in
order to be dressed and pushed out on stage.
In this state Pink conceptualizes himself
in an alter-ego, a fascist dictator indoctrinating
teens, primed by a conformist education system,
into hate and violence.
This sequence, spanning the songs In The Flesh,
Run Like Hell, and Waiting for the Worms,
includes dramatization of hate crimes and
sexual assault.
The film’s imagery of crossed hammers, invented
for the movie as a deliberately unsettling
expression of contemporary fascism and its
ability to utilize the banal, the blunt, the
simplistic, was adopted in 1988 by actual
neo-Nazi group the Hammerskins, a now fractured
organization whose dispersed members remain
active in other hate organizations to this
day.
The potent imagery, structured as a condemnation,
was still adopted by people who saw the violence
not as horrifying but as aspirational.
The character of Pink holds fears and resentments
towards women that are emotionally challenging
to watch expressed on screen and while a mature
audience can certainly parse the difference
between a character’s excuses and reality,
the film’s lack of closure means there’s
little guidance on what the audience is ultimately
meant to take away from the depictions of
Pink being devoured by a predatory, vaginal
flower.
And part of that is rooted in the film’s
emotional rawness, the dark place of the psyche
where thoughts and fears and beliefs are not
rational but are deeply potent and extremely
present.
Pink intellectually understands that his own
self-destruction and alienation drove his
wife away, but emotionally still conceptualizes
her as a consuming predator.
It doesn’t all make sense or resolve or
coalesce because we don’t all make sense.
Everyone is the illusion of order constructed,
brick by brick, out of chaos.
So, while The Wall is far from flawless and
certainly not for everyone, there are still,
I feel, deep emotional truths in there, a
human story about the contradiction of being,
the self-amplifying spiral of isolation, and
the fragility and hypocrisy of power.
The album is good, but it was always written
with a visual component in mind, be it the
concert or the film, and I think the album
definitely feels less than whole as a result.
The movie also adds ‘When the Tigers Broke
Free’, which is a song that I think adds
a lot of welcome depth to the story.
It’s a really potent encapsulation of how
Waters feels about the system that killed
his father.
[singing] And that’s how the high command
took my daddy from me
And this is a movie that Doug Walker, a man
whose bread and butter is getting irrationally
angry at movies for 9 year olds, decided to
riff in the form of a parody recreation.
[singing] Good old Pink Floyd made a movie
devoid of even the slightest bit of subtlety.
Okay, so, what is this?
Why does this exist?
I’m going to have to say a bunch of unkind
things, and there’s really no way around
that, because the observable facts are just,
prima facia, unkind.
[Dracula voice] Well, maybe it’s the other
way alound, I don’t know, I’ve got a high
school education!
Muahahahah!
This is pandering like hell
Basically it’s impossible to engage with
something like The Wall, even sarcastically
or disingenuously, without leaving a lot of
yourself on the table as a result.
What you fixate on, what you think is silly,
why you think it’s silly, these are all
revealing.
And that’s not to say that you need to love
The Wall or even like The Wall or, you know,
you’re a phoney or a poser or shallow if
you don’t, it’s just that defending that
position is going to demand emotional honesty.
For most critics that’s not a problem, but,
we’ll see.
The Nostalgia Critic, AKA The Critic, AKA
That Guy With The Glasses is the brainchild
of Doug Walker, an aspiring filmmaker from the suburbs of Chicago who, in 2008, stumbled
into an early online video success with the
then-nascent genre of angry reviews.
The basic format, more or less unchanged in
13 years, involves a recap of the plot of
a film interspersed with one-liners and skits,
usually with the comedy predicated on slapstick
reactions of either extreme confusion or extreme
anger or both.
Seven million.
Never leave the cave without it.
A bat credit card?
They gave him a bat credit card?
They had the BALLS to give one of THE GREATEST
SUPER HEROES OF ALL TIME A BAT CREDIT CARD?!
In September 2019 they published Nostalgia
Critic’s The Wall, a 40 minute musical review
featuring musician Corey Taylor, his son Griff
Taylor, and the collaborative works of musician
Rob Scallon, and animator Fennah.
The reception was… not good.
[singing] all in all it’s just not very
funny at all
No exaggeration, I’m not being facetious,
I’m not trying to be a dick.
This is the worst movie review I have ever
seen.
When I first tried to watch Doug Walker’s
The Wall this is what happened to my computer,
so clearly it was trying to protect me.
This review has become somewhat notorious
online because there is something deeply compelling
about it.
[singing] The art-house ego-trip had fallen
and slipped to the bargain big for $3.93
There is a tremendous amount of effort on
display, but it’s also really lazy, if that
makes any sense.
The priority really seems to be in doing a
lot, doing everything, rather than doing any
of it particularly well.
And this is what’s confusing.
There’s so much going on, so many collaborations,
so many moving parts, that it clearly took
time and energy and passion, an energy and
passion that needs to be maintained on some
level for the weeks and weeks that it takes
to put all this together, but there’s no
evidence, whatsoever, of what was actually
driving that.
You don’t just make something like this
on accident in an afternoon.
This would have taken weeks, if not months,
to coordinate.
The collaborations with Satellite City and
Rob Scallon needed to be arranged, Corey Taylor
and his son needed to come out to Chicago,
the final version of The Trial probably took
eighty hours just to render, not even including
blocking and animating.
Then there’s writing, recording, props,
costumes, all of which you can cut a lot of
corners on, and make no mistake the corners
here are extremely cut, but there’s a floor.
Certain things are still going to take all
week no matter how half you ass them.
So on some level you have to care, you have
to care a lot to commit to this amount of
work.
And that passion, you know, it can come from
just really loving The Wall, or just really
hating The Wall, or feeling like you have
a lot of stuff to say about it, but it’s
gotta come from somewhere.
In the middle Doug does an ad for the companion
album, that they were selling – for money
– that Doug describes as a love letter to
Pink Floyd and their music, and it’s just…
This is just such a love letter to Pink Floyd’s
music and The Wall, and you can download the
album in the link below.
so hollow as a pitch because the product,
the thing that we’re watching and listening
to,
[singing] the art-house ego-trip
is extremely clearly not a love letter to
Pink Floyd, and is dominated by someone who,
based on the words being said, doesn’t seem
to know much about Pink Floyd at all in the
first place, and really doesn’t like what
they do know.
[singing] it’s us vs. them, I don’t even
know who us or them are, I just want to be
angry so I can be Tweeting
Doug doesn’t seem to understand The Wall
on even a surface level, and really just doesn’t
appear to care much about The Wall one way
or another, sort of?
There is at no point any sense that Doug has
any personal relationship to the material.
Based off the depth of Doug’s commentary
it reads very much like the opinions of someone
who watched The Wall for the first time after
already committing to do a full recreation,
and then didn’t particularly enjoy it, and
wasn’t really able to digest it because
the whole viewing went through the filter
of looking for ideas for the recreation.
The commentary is extremely shallow while
also being deeply petty and mean, but then
also the longer you go into the review the
further it drifts from even being about The
Wall and the more it becomes a showcase for
Doug’s own unrelated opinions.
There’s no clear sense of what viewpoints
the various characters are supposed to represent,
The Critic is used to voice multiple different
stances, being both critic, audience surrogate,
creator surrogate, narrator, and protagonist,
but then all of those are caked in various
layers of sarcasm that make it really difficult
to parse what the message is actually supposed
to be.
The whole of it is just very unclear.
The commentary, when it’s not completely
off topic, waffles between faint praise like
“well, I guess the song is kinda rad”
and really performatively cruel stuff, like
calling the creators clout-chasing fakes.
None of it feels like the kind of good-natured
ribbing you’d get from actually invested
fans who are making fun of a thing that they
love.
What’s missing, at the core, is any sense
of motivation.
That’s it?
We’re stopping there?
Well, yeah, the movie did.
I didn’t even get a line.
Hell, I didn’t even sing a song.
What’d you even think of the movie?
Well, the movie ended with such an open vagueness
that it only makes sense the review end on
such an open vagueness.
You get to the end and have no idea why this
was the form this product should take.
Why make a straight reproduction of pretty
much 50% of the entire film?
Why make a complete companion album?
Why put this much effort into a video about
a subject that you just don’t seem to have
any substantive opinions on at all?
And why put all this effort into this concept
for this specific movie?
I liked it fine.
Yeah, me too.
A little full of itself, but good music and
imagination.
Fair enough.
And having these questions afterwards is very
bizarre when you’re talking about a review,
something that is, theoretically at least,
predicated entirely on, ya know, talking about
your opinions.
And this is where we need to accept the reality
that this isn’t really a review, it’s
not a parody, it’s not a commentary, and
it’s not a spoof.
It’s barely even about The Wall.
It’s honestly closer to fanfiction, in a
way?
Doug wants to be a filmmaker, he wants to
make art, but he can’t, because he’s a
fundamentally incurious person who isn’t
much interested in what other people think
or feel, and all his ideas boil down to “what
if Batman met Mario?”
Slapstick focuses on the most important rule
of comedy, that all comedy is based in one
way or another on misery.
[teleporter noise] [fanfare]
With little to no dialogue, quickly identifiable
characters, and nothing but chases.
People see it as classic because it’s so
minimal, and yet so interesting.
It says so much with just a few clever choices.
‘Fury Road’ is the same way.
He is YouTube’s own home grown Tommy Wiseau
or Neil Breen, complete with the same unwillingness
to learn how a camera works.
Hey, so you invited me up here, what do you
want to do?
Just watch TV.
You invited me up here to literally watch
TV?
I’m a successful musician with millions,
how can you expect me to be happy?
It has that same heady mix of incompetence
and ego that is absolutely intoxicating to
talk about.
So much of the actual content is predicated
on readings of the material that are just
wildly wrong, and yet so absolutely confident
in their delivery.
Doug decided to accuse an eighty minute movie
of being too long and padded, and then didn’t
even flinch as he sandwiched that between
a rant about people being mean to him on Twitter
and an eight minute argument with a busty
nightmare squirrel.
And it’s that element, that deeply misplaced
sense of confidence that really just makes
Nostalgia Critic’s The Wall captivating.
Like The Room it’s a deeply cynical product
made by a fundamentally untalented man, bored
by the idea of personal growth, building so
many layers of self-protective irony that
it becomes unintentionally revealing.
You mean like ‘The Room’?
No.
Yes.
Shut up.
Doug is utilizing The Wall as a showcase for
his own ideas, his own lyricism, his own jokes,
his own singing.
This video is him strutting his stuff as a
filmmaker.
So while some of it is about The Wall, for
the most part the further you get into it
the more it shifts to just being about Doug.
This is a bit of a struggle to describe, which
is why I’m kinda repeating myself over and
over, but it makes sense when you see it.
[singing] Tweeting.
Waiting for the point.
A bunch of it is just disconnected Weird Al
style parody songs about things that grind
Doug’s gears, and the parts that are about
The Wall are, more often than not, so off
base that you would believe the entire thing
was recreated from decades old memories if
it weren’t for the granular details that
are included.
It is not Doug Walker’s review of The Wall,
it’s just Doug Walker’s version of The
Wall.
So let’s talk about some specifics.
[singing] Is this quite what you expected
to see?
Doug’s parody of Another Brick in the Wall
Part 2 is an immediate standout to people
as just one of the worst things they’ve
put in their brains that they didn’t find
on rotten.com
[singing] we need more victimization
[Dracula voice] there are no good teachers,
not one, not even by accident!
Restyled as ‘We Need More Victimization’
the song is simultaneously a criticism calling
The Wall whiney, engaging in bizarre whataboutism,
and a thinly veiled rant about online culture
war nonsense, a subject that will crop up
a few times throughout the video.
Most of the substance of this is contained
in Doug’s inexplicable Dracula impression.
[Dracula voice] Welcome to high school where
all the teachers are monsters!
I know it looks like they want to teach you
something, but they don’t!
They just want to eat you up because we’re
evil bloodsucking vampire things!
Mwahahaha!
Doug’s argument here is that everyone thinks
school sucks, that that opinion isn’t special
or noteworthy or substantive, that The Wall
is just dunking on school because it’s a
popular opinion with teenagers, and, the bizarre
whataboutism of pointing out funding issues
with the American public education system,
while throwing in some stale jabs about school
teaching algebra instead of car maintenance.
So you know what we teach in these walls?
How to fix a car, pay your taxes, ace an interview,
perform first aid, manage your insurance,
cook healthy meals, or do household repairs?
Preposterous!
We pay other people to do those things.
We teach important things you need to know
in life, like algebra.
[singing] oh our education system’s broke
[Dracula voice] Well, maybe it’s the other
way alound, I don’t know, I’ve got a high
school education!
Muahahahah!
This is pandering like hell
[singing] L-O-L so school sucks, grow a damn
pair of balls.
Now, at the surface level here it just needs
to be said, Doug is transparently imposing
his own experience of school in 1980s 1990s
suburban Illinois on Waters’ experiences
in Primary School in the 1950s and 60s.
In England.
So just at a very fundamental level this doesn’t
work because it’s a complete non-sequitur.
It’s a response to Another Brick In The
Wall that’s so off topic, that misses the
mark by such a wide mile, that it’s clear
he just wasn’t paying attention.
More than that, though, what interests me
here is the way that this version is an argument
in support of the status quo.
Let’s talk about the grim cowardice of “school
helps you get a job.”
[Dracula voice] It’s all part of our seclet
plan to make sure you’re more likely to
get a job when you’re older!
Like, okay, let me back up a bit and illustrate
the problem here.
The roots of public education are split between
two major motivators, the first being philosophical,
and the second being industrial.
The philosophical argument is that knowledge
is inherently valuable, and it is a moral
good for society to educate everyone, that
a society with a widespread familiarity with
the physical sciences, mathematics, ethics,
literature, and the arts is a more inventive
society, and a more ethical society.
The industrial argument is that school should
exist to prepare you to work.
This is rooted in the real history of much
of public education, as early efforts to expand
public education were driven by industrialists
whose growing empires needed more specialized
laborers to do the work of middle management,
which mostly means accounting.
The idea, from their perspective, was you
could convince the government to teach everyone
the reading, writing, and arithmetic needed
to do the job, which would make it easier
to fill all the positions needed, lower training
costs, and drive down the price of math and
literacy based labour.
This second argument has had a lot of power
and influence over the shape of education
in the last two centuries, and is still alive
and well today.
There is a tremendous amount of ongoing debate
in education circles about the balance between
raw theory and the pragmatic modern reality
of labour.
There’s tons of people who will argue that
we should really have two school tracks, so
that the students who just aren’t that interested
in math and Shakespeare, who think algebra
is useless, can go watch Amazon training videos
for a couple years and get right to work in
the fulfilment warehouse.
The criticism, which Waters is directly engaging
with in Another Brick in the Wall Part 2,
is that this arrangement, school as a pipeline
to industry, means that what is taught in
school and how it is taught will be dictated
by industrialists, by corporations.
The school system, then, becomes nothing but
a systematic reshaping of children into ideal
workers: obedient, compliant, and narrowly
trained in only what is needed for the job.
It is a reduction of people to exploitable
labour, to uniform bricks in a wall.
It is critical of the fundamental ordering
of society.
Why should these institutions, rampant with
abuse and steered by corporate ghouls, be
given so much power over us?
Why, especially, should they be given so much
power over children?
This all is part of the multi-layered metaphor
of The Wall.
There is the autobiographical element, placed
in the specifics of English primary school
in the 1950s and 60s, and the ways that those
experiences shaped Waters into the adult he
became, which then serves as a means to criticize
the existence of the system itself, because
the abuses he suffered, the physical violence
of beating children who failed in the rote
recitation of number tables, were systematized,
and took place within a system that was at
best indifferent and at worst approving.
This continues to resonate with people to
this day because regardless of whether or
not corporal punishment has been abolished
and more idealistic pedagogies have prevailed,
institutionalized school is still an institution
and will never be an unalloyed good.
It will always be vulnerable to corruption,
to abuse, to manipulation, and the question
of whose agenda is served by the structure
and material must remain an eternal debate.
So, yeah, I feel confident saying that Doug’s
argument here just isn’t very well formed,
it’s unclear, shallow, and doesn’t actually
engage with the question.
D minus.
Wait time out, is this really a World War
2 reference?
No, it’s just a bunch of kids being herded
onto a train to a horrible torturous building,
ooooh
Yeah, and we’re really comparing this to
high school?
Following “We Need More Victimization”
is an extended skit where Doug, dressed as
The Critic, defends The Wall from criticism.
No, no, it’s just meant to look weird and
creepy.
They’re not implying… that.
The Critic is positioned as the rube, his
defences are clearly meant to be hollow and
weak.
The problem is that the accusations he’s
sarcastically defending the movie against
only hold weight based on Doug’s own shallow
misreading of everything else up to this point.
In The Wall Pink, as a child, hiding in a
train tunnel, sees schoolchildren as faceless
blobs crowded into cattle cars, and envisions
himself, too, becoming faceless.
This is the beginning of ‘The Happiest Days
of Our Lives’ which is effectively just
the intro to Another Brick in the Wall Part
2, during which the faceless children are
fed into a meat grinder.
So the more immediate imagery is a slaughterhouse.
Is that, in part or by extension, also a Holocaust
reference?
Yeah, it is.
It is a “world war 2 reference.”
Because much of the album and movie are about
the after effects of that war.
It’s not an abstract concept that’s just
being name-dropped for aesthetic symmetry,
it’s a real event that people lived through,
and The Wall is in no small part a reflection
on growing up in the shadow of that and reflecting
on the value of it, or more specifically the
lack thereof.
The statement is that the inhumanity of the
system, its goals and methods, are ultimately
homoousian, of the same stuff, as the inhumanity
that leads a system to load humans into cattle
cars.
That comparison is only inappropriate if,
one, you think the message is simply “school
sucks”, and two, you’ve been ignoring
the role of World War 2 within the film up
to this point.
Oh come on, they’re just saying school sucks,
they’re not making any connections to that.
Now let’s go on to the next song that talks
about eh horrors of World War 2, ah crap.
See.
It’s just a coincidence!
Maybe?
I don’t know.
As those of you familiar with The Wall may
have noticed, this is all out of order because
the joke doesn’t work if you do it in order.
Doug’s joke is a setup for his version of
Goodbye Blue Sky, retooled as So Long, Weird
Song.
[singing] D-d-d-d-doesn’t this seem too
heavy?
Is World War 2 with monsters too silly?
Originally this is all the other way around.
Goodbye Blue Sky leads into the train tunnel
which segues into Another Brick pt. 2.
The reason that matters is because originally
the imagery of Goodbye Blue Sky is the setup
for later imagery.
Gerald Scarfe’s powerful visualization of
the War and specifically The Blitz as a psychological
force that scarred the collective psyche of
the people as deeply as it scarred the land
and the bodies of soldiers.
Like, I cannot stress this enough, Goodbye
Blue Sky is one of the most potent pieces
of filmmaking I’ve ever seen.
It is ruinously effective at using its imagery
to convey the sheer scale of damage and waste
that the war represents.
It’s grim, and haunting, and very important
as a foundation for what follows.
In ‘So Long, Weird Song’ Doug asks if
“world war 2 with monsters” is too silly
for a movie that also complains about how
High School bites.”
[singing] D-d-d-d-doesn’t this seem too
heavy?
Is World War 2 with monsters too silly?
Oh Roger Waters did you ever wonder why these
images of slaughter made it in a film that
also sings about how high school bites?
Which, of course, again, is predicated on
that actually being the message, which it
isn’t, and indulges in a deeply misplaced
level of literalism by describing the sequence
as “world war 2 with monsters” as though
this were a direct-to-video Pacific Rim sequel.
Now, this kind of literalism is a pretty regular
part of Doug’s normal bit, it just really
falls apart here.
It’s one thing when it’s aimed at corporate
franchise schlock aimed at kids, but it’s
just really obviously misplaced and inappropriate
when applied to a deeply earnest piece of
art that is overtly symbolic, unapologetically
symbolic in its attempt to communicate what
this real event, that really happened, felt
like to live through.
He also calls the song “Oscar bait”, which
is funny because it’s both literally wrong,
Goodbye Blue Sky wasn’t eligible for an
Oscar in the first place, and also because
it’s such a deep insult that it’s really
revealing.
[singing] So long Oscar bait song.
Smoke a bong and it’ll feel less wrong.
Now, I actually don’t think Doug was literally
calling the song “Oscar bait”, I don’t
think he thinks they were specifically playing
towards the Academy, but I do think that he
thinks The Wall is spiritually Oscar bait,
which is to say insincere.
The capstone here, for me, is the replacement
animation, which is, first of all, just visually
awful and cheap in a way that would be considered
sub-par for 2007, and second, is just so petty
and mean that this is what makes it very funny
when Doug calls his album a “love letter
to Pink Floyd”.
The imperial eagle is labeled Ego, and the
frightened ones are labeled self-content?
Self-content?
I honestly can’t tell if that’s supposed
to be content or content because neither really
makes sense?
I think he’s saying ego is the destroyer
of self-content?
Like, Roger Waters’ dissatisfaction is not
the result of any real problems, but is a
product of his own ego?
That would parse, because the lyrics of the
song do directly address Roger Waters, and
later a cloud labeled “my problems” grows
flowers of pity and then blasts another cloud
labeled “other people’s problems.”
[singing] ooooooh oooooh ooooooh oooooooh
I dunno, I think it’s one thing to describe
The Wall as whiney or juvenile, to say in
effect that it encapsulates a really teenage
mindset, but it’s quite another to accuse
the creators of being disingenuous, ego-tripping
fakes who milk imaginary problems for pity.
I don’t think you can make that accusation
and then turn around and insist that you liked
it fine, and made a love letter to its creative
vision.
That’s the kind of thing that you say about
something you just really don’t think very
highly of at all.
[singing] That’s why I watch, despite it
being so whiny, ya see.
[singing] This is pandering like hell
[singing] So long Oscar bait song
[singing] You’re not Oscar bound
This is such a love letter to Pink Floyd’s
music and The Wall
The song Comfortably Numb, retooled as Comfortably
Dumb, is where things start to really wander
off topic.
It’s not really about The Wall but it’s
kinda about Doug’s relationship to The Wall,
and to media in general, and it’s probably
the most honest song Doug put into the project,
almost certainly not on purpose.
Nominally it’s about the pacing of the film,
and Doug reiterates once again that he thinks
Roger Waters’ opinions are the illegitimate
whining of a millionaire, but it’s also
Doug saying he doesn’t understand and he
doesn’t care to.
The movie is challenging and he just doesn’t
have any interest in engaging with it on its
own terms.
He has become comfortably dumb.
[singing] I just don’t understand, is this
now how I am?
I have become comfortably dumb.
And, you know what, I’m not going to disagree.
You said it, man.
I don’t know if it works as self-deprecating
humour because I don’t think it’s comedically
true, I think it’s just true.
Going into the ad break there’s a changeover.
So, okay, up to this point Corey Taylor, the
frontman for nu metal band Slipknot, has been
playing the equivalent role of Pink.
As they transition Corey is replaced with
Doug, so Doug plays Pink for the equivalents
of In The Flesh and Waiting for the Worms.
This is part of a running gag, being that
the actual rock musician doesn’t get to
sing a song until the very end at which point
he plays the Spongebob Squarepants theme,
and also probably just a logistical extension
of only getting Corey out for a day or two
and block shooting all his stuff.
The other thing that’s going on, which is
far more trivial but bothers me so much, is
that the exterior shot is overwhelmingly blue,
and I’m not sure if this is a stylistic
choice or a mistake, that they just forgot
to set the white balance properly and just
left it.
Because Doug does that, just, all the time.
After the ad break, which consists of an uncomfortably
over-acted ad for online data harvesting scam
Honey and Doug’s own tie-in recreation of
the entire album The Wall, which, again, they
were selling for money, we get this.
[Music: ‘In The Flesh’]
Truly every frame is a painting.
[singing] Well I’m that nameless foe, ha!
No, okay, so, mm, where do I start with this?
[singing] I got some weird news for you sunshine.
This was dissin’ Thatcher’s administration.
But it’s vague enough to put anyone you
feel.
Politician, showman, just put their face here!
No, no doug.
No.
No, it really wasn’t.
[singing] Are there any queers in the audience
tonight?
It really, it really, really wasn’t that
vague.
[singing] That one looks Jewish, and that
one’s a coon!
Not vague at all.
[singing] Get ‘em up against the wall!
(Against!
The!
Wall!)
Not even a teeny tiny bit vague.
[Doug singing] That one’s looking stressed,
he wants to feel oppressed.
Put him in the wall!
(Post!)
Okay, so this whole segment is just Doug venting
about people being mean to him on Twitter.
It is completely disconnected from The Wall,
not even a tiny bit about the movie, it’s
just Doug using the veil of alter ego to express
an otherwise authentically held belief.
And that’s honestly a charitable reading
of it.
Because otherwise you’re saying that a criticism
of Thatcherism, the policies of austerity,
of rigid enforcement of Christian norms, the
violent suppression of political dissent,
of a rising home-grown fascist movement, criticisms
that pre-date the AIDS crisis but would hold
true well into the 80s as governments decided
it was unofficial policy that AIDS was a divine
punishment and a solution to their “gay
crisis,” you’re saying that all that isn’t
substantively different from people yelling
at each other on the internet over Batman
movies.
[singing] that one looks like he really wants
to be outraged!
Now with social media you have the stage!
So, yeah, I think the most charitable read
is that Doug’s just talking about himself.
[chanting] Hashtag!
Hashtag!
Alright, there’s only one major section
left and this is maybe where I risk a controversial
opinion.
Common among reactions to this video is to
say that while the review as a whole is really
bad, the animation at the end is really good,
it’s the best part, and anyone who is criticizing
the review should, you know, be kind to Fennah,
the animator who put it all together, because
it was a lot of work.
So what happens is Corey enters the Channel
Awesome office and is about to confront Doug
when Doug is interrupted by a phone call.
Or is it just a misguided ego trip into self-indulgent
world that we all live in, pardon!
Who is it?!
Hello there, critic.
It’s Sullivan Croft.
The Satellite City guy?
Yes, actually.
Um, I was, uh, is Lucy Lacemaker there?
Is she there?
‘Cus I was, ah, it’s just a thing
[crosstalk] S-sullivan, have you found her
yet?
Uh, shut the fuck up.
Now, I’ve done all the research to piece
all this together so that I can summarize
it, but on first viewing I had zero clue what
was going on.
I don’t know who this is, but it’s clearly
a reference that the video expects me to get,
there’s clearly some sort of backstory to
these characters, it’s not just an abstraction,
and just to really add to the confusion the
whole thing is this mumblecore overlapping
ramble, and it looks like garbage, and you
can’t understand what they’re talking
about because you can’t understand what
they’re even saying.
You’re not exactly giving creation all of
its credit, it’s not like you just shit
out the Horcrux that Voldemort never meant
to make.
And then this thing shows up and the barely
intelligible dialogue just keeps going until
the whole thing segues into The Trial where
it honestly doesn’t get much easier to understand
[singing] Lazy.
Constantly ???????????????? Lazy
Now, before we get into this any further,
yes, there’s a lot of technical competency
on display.
Modelling is hard, texturing is hard, rigging
is hard, animation is hard, hair simulations
are hard, all of this represents hours and
hours and hours and hours of work.
There is a lot of effort on display here.
Okay.
So, Fennah is a YouTube animator who makes
a series called Satellite City which is, I
guess, a skit show with a combination of live
action and CG animation and way, way, way
too much lore for a series with an average
episode runtime of one hundred and thirty
seconds.
So the characters in The Trial are all characters
from Satellite City, and it’s just, it’s
not good.
Kinda the real change of pace is that it’s
not good in ways that are new to the review
so far.
From what I can glean this segment was made
by Fennah more or less in isolation from the
rest of the video.
The track on the album is called Fennah’s
The Trial, the credits say it’s produced
by Fennah, and so it does seem like Fennah
wrote and produced all of it, using his normal
stable of voice actors.
Which makes sense because the opinions are
bad, but they’re a different kind of bad.
The entire song is sung in-universe from the
viewpoint of these characters who feel that
The Wall falls short because all the animated
monsters in the movie didn’t get enough
screen time or development, and then another
character comes in and says that, you know,
I guess we can give it a pass because it wasn’t
trying to tell a story.
[singing] This film's not bound by characters
It's a visual affair It never aimed to tell
a story Rather, a sprawling canvas of emotion,
visual splendor
Okay, so this sucks.
That’s just a really weak, disingenuous
argument being filtered through a character
in order to scrub it of any meaning or ownership,
because heaven forbid you put an actual opinion
out into the world.
It’s also just wrong at a very basic level.
The Wall is telling a story.
It’s not conventionally told, and it’s
a little loose, but it’s very comprehensible.
The animated monsters at the end of the movie
aren’t under-developed in the slightest,
because they’re extensions and representations
of characters that were already present in
the rest of the movie.
They are a psychosexual visualization of those
literal characters and the ideas those characters
represent: parents, the state, the education
system, intimate partners.
The problem with using Fennah’s horny edgelord
steampunk furry OCs is that they actually
are underdeveloped.
If there’s even an attempt at using them
in a metaphorical fashion then that’s lost
in the clear specificity of the crossover.
They’re not present in any meaningful capacity
through the rest of the review, they don’t
represent anything substantive, and they are,
for the most part, awful over-baked designs
for one-note characters.
fills me with the urge to decapitate!
So you’re going to have this over-designed
horny rat thing lecture about how The Wall
is all style over substance, devoid of intellectual
development, then alien big titty goth girlfriend
calls the movie lazy?
And when I heard you were reviewing the much-to-be-desired
Wall I figured I’d find my own tuppence.
Style over substance, showcasing a bunch of
weird creatures and worlds, not a drop of
intellectual development.
[singing] Lazy.
Constantly ???????????????? Lazy
Cringe.
There’s no other word for it.
This makes me cringe.
It’s embarrassing.
On a deep level the entire structure of this
just doesn’t work.
It’s poor criticism and it’s not even
an appropriate parallel to the segment that
it’s a recreation of.
If this were actually a coherent work this
isn’t where you would put the movie on trial,
this is where you would put Doug on trial.
This is where you would take all the other
ideas from the rest of the review, consolidate
them in one place, interrogate them, and interrogate
what they say about their author.
So, no, I don’t think this is the “good
part” of the review, because it’s still
a tremendous amount of effort put into modelling,
texturing, and rigging a fundamentally bad
concept.
Just at the basics it’s confusing and muddled.
Creatively it seems to have started from the
ending, the chant of Tear Down The Wall, taken
from the original and recontextualized to
mean tear down The Wall, the movie, and working
backwards from that is a bunch of stuff just
hammered into place because if you’re doing
a full recreation then you’ve gotta put
something in there.
You’ve got a lyric sheet to fill out and
time to kill.
And of course, afterwards, the whole review
ends with a lazy lampshade of the fact that
the review didn’t actually contain anything
of substance.
Okay!
I liked it fine.
Yeah, me too.
A little full of itself, but good music and
imagination.
Fair enough.
And the resolution of the gag that Corey Taylor
hasn’t done anything yet in the form of
the Spongebob Squarepants theme song.
[singing] Spongebob Squarepants!
Kinda the buckwild thing here is that if there
were less effort put into this, if the substance
was otherwise exactly the same but there wasn’t
a companion album on sale for money, there
wasn’t an entire end-to-end abridged recreation,
if there were just one or two songs and a
bunch of lazy jokes about the movie being
really pretentious, then I don’t think this
would compel people in the way it does.
There’s an effort on display that is its
own form of earnestness, and it just all falls
flat, because it’s just no good.
It’s trying to be impressive without being
vulnerable.
And simultaneous to that it’s pissing on
a really earnest piece of art specifically
for being vulnerable.
And to see this all played out against the
backdrop of a movie from a band that is decades
and decades and decades old, well outside
Doug’s normal wheelhouse, with no clear
indication of why this particular movie, this
album, is something that Doug feel is worth
this much effort, it’s a baffling product.
[Hat!Dan] But wait!
Holy crap!
It’s long running character Hat!Dan, the
Dan With a Hat!
What did you really think of it?!
I liked it fine.
A little full of itself but they put in a
lot of effort.
yeah!
Yeah!
[gunshots]